Okay, folks. up.
I I hope you had a chance to read that
email I sent yesterday. Right. It lines
up what's left in this
class. Okay. So, help me out here, Jake.
What is the first thing that's that's
coming during this class?
We have the f third quiz on Monday.
Right. Right. Third quiz on Monday.
First 30 minutes of class,
you have to submit the numbers into the
spreadsheet by by
the stop May 9th midnight, right?
Midnight is midnight. That same night
day, right? It says April 4th, midnight.
It's midnight of that day, not the
previous day, otherwise it'll be May
3rd, midnight, right? May 4th, midnight.
You know what I mean by submitting your
numbers, right? Remember that master
spreadsheet way back in time where I
made you enter your name and actually
not your name but your company name?
That spreadsheet has columns for what
your DCF value is, what your pricing is,
and what your recommendation is.
Clearly, you're not there yet, right?
Your DCF value you've got at least for
the moment, but that could shift between
now and May 5th as to what your
recommendation is. So, we'll close
trading for this class on Friday at
close of trading, right? Because
obviously you can't do it on Monday if
you're turning in on Sunday. So, you're
going to tell me as of Friday what your
recommendation is. Wait till Friday to
make your recommendation.
Why? What's the recommendation based on
price? Right? You can get your DCF value
and you can get your pricing, but the
world keeps shifting on you. So wait
till the close of trading on Friday. Put
your recommendation in. So that's going
to go in on May 4th. Why do I need that?
I need that for May 5th's class. That's
why I need it by May 4th because I'm
going to show you what you found now.
Undervalued, overvalued, most
undervalued, most overvalued. So I need
that on May 4th. May 5th, of course,
your final project is due by the by I
think 5:00 p.m. that day. So that is the
actual written project. So May 4th is
just the numbers. May 5th, is that
written up as a project? So, I'll send
you more clarity on that because there's
already past projects. You can look at
them, but I'll kind of pull it all
together in
tomorrow's email where I'll send a to-do
list on what's left on the project as
well as what the final format should
look like. Less involved than you think.
And then what's
left? The final exam. And I've given you
options, right? What are the options?
First, you can take it in person or take
it
online. You can take it early or you can
take it on really I mean it's really one
day May 12 May 12th. So it's that that
day you can take it'll be essentially
the same exam. The own only reason I've
given you both options. Some of you
might be traveling. So we'll work out if
everybody decides I'll start a Google
shared spreadsheet. If everybody decides
to take it in person I will get another
room again. So you have two different
rooms. So that's what's left on the
class.
Yeah, not necessarily. I'm still working
on it because if I can grade it easily
online with regular questions, I'm going
to prefer to keep it regular because
that way you don't have this all or
nothing phenomenon play out. But I'm
actually running a test quiz with with a
few people to see how easy it is to
grade things online. Because if I get
300 people turning everything online, if
everybody decides to take it online, it
gets really messy to grade it online, I
want to create that. So, first I want to
make sure what grading it online is
going to be feasible. I'll let you know
by the end of this week what my decision
is. Okay? So, lots coming at you. So,
today we have one more item in the
agenda. We're going to talk about
valuing private companies. Continue that
discussion. So, you can look at the
slide, but it's not there yet. So, let
me turn that on.
people who came in here they wiped out
all my zoom meetings so I had to kind of
create it
so so let's talk about private company
valuation so while the slide comes on
you know I'm going to start with a
question that I can frame in terms
of so let's suppose I have two private
businesses yara owns a privatelyowned
business She's the sole owner,
right? You're all investors in a
publicly traded company and the two
businesses look exactly alike. Cash
flows and growth. When my question is a
very narrow one, it's about the cost of
equity you're going to use to value that
company. Same kind. So, business looks
exactly the same. Yara owns one. She's
the sole owner. That's all her wealth is
tied up in it. Your investors. Which of
the companies is going to have the
higher cost of equity?
No, no, wait, wait. Lo, don't go there.
Right. You don't have to be marginal. If
you're investing in a public company,
that's out of your hands, right? You
have to be price
takers. So, in a public company, even if
you're not diversified, guess what? You
entered the game. You got to play the
game based on the marginal investors.
It's not based on you. It's based on
them. But you're in the investor in the
public. You're answering for Yara or
you're answering for
yourself. No, you're investing in a
public company.
Yeah. Will have the higher cost. Tell me
why. What is it that Yara sees that you
don't? Same company. You're a public
market investor. She has her entire
wealth invested in it. So, what does she
see that lead her leads her to having a
higher cost of
equity? Exactly. her entire wealth is
tied up in the company. So when she
looks at the risk of the company, what
does she see? She sees all risk, right?
You don't have the luxury of saying this
is market risk, this is company specific
risk. It'll get diversified away by
whom, right? So today we're going to
talk about adjusting the cost of equity
for the fact that if you're not
diversified, you see old risk. If you
see old risk, you got to adjust the cost
of equity to reflect it.
There's a second item that's going to
come up with private company valuation
that's a little tricky. In our in all of
the public companies that we valued,
we've never talked about liquidity,
right? It's not been an issue. So why
aren't we dealing with liquidity?
Obviously, it should be a factor for
investors. So why when we value public
companies is liquidity a non-issue?
Samita, you want to try that? Why is
liquidity not even being considered?
It's on a value
company. You can trade, but when you
trade, what price do you buy at and what
price do you sell at? I mean, in the
public market, there's a price, right,
that you see. But is that just one price
for a
company? There's a spread. There's a
price at which you can buy and a price
at which you can sell. The price at
which you can sell will be lower than
the price. It's called the bid ask
spread.
You know why we don't talk about ill
liquidity with public companies? It
takes care of itself. So let's say you
value a company and you find it
undervalued. You go to your brokerage
account, you try to buy it. You're going
to get it at the higher price in the
spread. And if there's a lot of
illquidity, that spread can be wide
enough that you decide not to buy the
stock because the spread is too wide.
The the bid ass spread in the market
takes care of illquidity. So there's
nothing explicit you have to do. But if
you're valing a private business,
illquidity hasn't been dealt with
directly. You have to bring it
in. What kind of private business am I
talking about? Let's say on your way out
this evening, you're
tired. You stop on your way out that hot
dog stand outside and you buy the stand.
Why? Moment of weakness. You take your
entire savings. You buy that hot dog
stand and then you get back home and
say, "What the heck did I do? I sold all
my stocks to buy a hot dog stand. I need
to sell it off. You come back and you
stand on the sidewalk there and as
people walk, would you like to buy a hot
dog stand? How about you? You look like
you have a lot of money." Much more
difficult to reverse a bad decision when
you're talking about private businesses.
So, you know what you do with private
businesses upfront? you value the
private business and then you discount
the value for illquidity. So I
understand the logic but I want to ask
you a pragmatic question. If you want to
discount the value and you're looking at
four types of private businesses I want
you to tell me what kinds of private
businesses you might attach a higher
discount to and what kinds of private.
So let's start with the first choice.
You have two private businesses. One is
healthy and cash flow generating. The
other is money losing and has negative
cash flows. In which one would you
discount the value more for
liquidity and tell me why with a money-m
company you settle for a lesser
discount and also you have the cash
flows coming in right part of the reason
you're selling is to get the cash flows.
The business itself throws off cash
flows. Your discount should be smaller.
You'd expect the discount to be smaller
for money making cash flow generating
companies and money losing
companies. But u liquidity is also buyer
specific. Let's say I'm looking at two
types of buy buyers. One is a long-term
buyer who has no need for cash in the
near term. Why? Because they're making
enough money from their jobs. They don't
need the cash. The other is a cash
constrained buyer where you're one
crisis away from needing the cash
flows. Who's going to have the higher
discount? the long-term buyer or the
cash constraint buyer.
Yeah.
Oh, you'd like to pay everybody likes to
pay a lower price, but think in terms of
your need for
liquidity. If you're cash constraint,
you're going to say, I care more about
liquidity because I might need the cash
next week. And if you might need the
cash next week, you're going to
preemptively pay less upfront because
you might need the
cash. Your discount should vary across
companies. It should vary across
buyers. Should it vary across time? If
you're trying to sell a private business
today as opposed to 6 months ago, I'm
going to argue probably going to demand
a bigger discount now than six months
ago. Why? Uncertainties have increased.
So if the market itself becomes more
uncertain, the things that cause the
price of risk to change, your liquidity
discount should also
increase. One of my pet peeves with how
private company appraisers deal with the
liquidity is they treat it as a
bludgeon. What does that mean? Every
company they knock off 20% of the value
and that makes no sense to me. It should
vary across companies. It should vary
across buyers and should vary across
time. So we'll talk about different ways
in which people estimate discounts and
whether they meet that
test. One final question. You own a
private business. Let's go back to Yara.
She owns a private business. She's
looking for a potential buyer for the
business. So Yara, you want a high value
for your company or a low value when you
sell it? High value. So I want to ask
what kind of buyer will most likely to
pay you a high value? Is it going to be
another private
individual, a private equity
fund, or potentially a publicly traded
company?
And tell me
why. Because they don't worry about this
this diversification issue. They don't
care. Why don't publicly traded
companies care about ili
liquidity? Because after they buy your
company, it becomes part of a publicly
traded company. If investors want
liquidity, what do they do? They sell
the shares. those two big issues hanging
over private company valuations kind of
go away. So today, those are the issues
we're going to talk about. How to adjust
cost of equity for lack of
diversification. But already we've kind
of set the table for what's
coming. So let's go back to where we
were at the end of the last session. I'd
set up, you know, private companies. I
said motive matters. Tell me why you
want to value because that can affect
value. So I'm going to look at four
types of private company transactions
starting with the most difficult. The
most challenging is one private business
owner is trying to sell to another
private individual private to private.
Then I'm going to go to the other
extreme. The easiest evaluations is
private selling to a public company
because all the problems go away. The
third I'm going to talk about private
going public. You basically go public.
So it's an IPO. It's kind of a variant
of the second with a few twists added to
the IPO process. And the last one is a
private company that goes to a venture
capitalist or a private equity investor
to raise money. So, it's not quite as
good as selling to a public company, but
it might get you partway there. So,
let's start with a private private
transaction and talk a little bit about
what it is that makes a private private
transaction tricky.
First, neither the buyer nor the seller
is usually diversified. They probably in
in in fact this in specifically the
buyer is likely not to be diversified.
I'll give you a classic example. Until
very recently, probably until the last
10 or 15 years, if you were a doctor or
a dentist, you owned your own practice.
The last 20 years has changed. Now,
healthcare has shifted. You used to own
your own practice.
Unfortunately, time works on you just
like everybody else. You get older as a
doctor or a dentist. You get to be 70
years old and you decide to sell your
practice. And in the no again going back
20 years, who do you sell your practice
to? Another young doctor wanting to buy
your practice. Why are they buying your
practice? Because they get a whole set
of patients that come with the practice.
Now, if you're a 70-y old doctor and you
made a know significant amount of money
over your lifetime, maybe you have a
401k, you got a, you know, money invest.
But if you're a 35y old doctor buying
your practice, odds are you're investing
everything you have and more to buy the
practice because you got 10 years of
medical school debt to begin with. Your
balance sheet looks really bad right
now. You're the exact opposite of
diversified. So that's the first thing
you deal with is neither the buyer or
seller meets that nice diversified
requirement that we use to get to betas.
Second, it's definitely liquid. You buy
that practice and you change your mind
15 minutes later, you're going to go
through a painful process of trying to
sell that practice with an added
complication of people who say, "What
did you find out in the 15 minutes that
makes you want to sell the practice that
quickly?" So you've actually poisoned
the well.
Third, there's a key person issue. Do
you see how this plays out in a medical
practice? I mean, when you go to see a
doctor, you don't see just the DR, you
see the name after that, the person
you're it this is as much a personal
relationship, less so than it used to be
decades
ago. But if you walked into your
doctor's office and there was somebody
you'd never seen sitting in that at that
table, odds are you're going to be a
little queasy about who this person is.
You've never seen the person before. or
they have all your records in front of
them. They say, "I don't know you. Who
the heck are you?" And if this is
actually a doctor's practice, you might
leave that room, in which case you might
be listed as a client in this practice,
a patient in the practice, but you're
not going to be a continuing patient.
Which means if I'm trying to sell the
practice to you as a 70-year-old doctor,
you built this great practice. Many of
those people might not show up if you
buy the practice from that because they
don't know who you are. there's a key
person discount. So, lots of little
technical issues we've got to deal with
which can affect the value. So, let me
set this process up with a hypothetical
kind of simple private company that I'm
going to
value. So, there are two players in this
game. One is a French chef, the other is
an investment banker tired of doing
investment banking. Which role do you
want to
play? You play the investment banker
tire. It'll happen very quickly. It's
it's not a question of weather. It's a
question of when, right?
I'm a French chef. I'm the furthest
thing from a but let's say I'm a French
chef. I'm a well-known French chef at
this restaurant. It's a great
restaurant. I'm trying to sell it.
You're planning to buy this restaurant
with your entire wealth. This is going
to become part of your story. So, I'm
going to liquidate everything. You're
going to buy this restaurant. Okay. I'm
going to give you access to my financial
statements. Looks like a, you know, it's
a pretty successful restaurant. Last
year, I had $1.2 million in revenues and
$400,000 in operating income. And I was
running pretty much at full capacity.
You know, at full capacity restaurants,
right? There are certain number of
tables, you know, and chairs. You can
have only so many seings in a night,
right? Two, three, and you basically
have them
up. The firm is no conventional debt.
The bank in this case, the restaurant is
no conventional debt, but it does have a
lease commitment for that restaurant
space. That's $120,000 each year for the
next 12 years.
So, let's work through how much you as
the investment banker will be willing to
pay for this restaurant. So, here are
the past income statements and I'm going
to be open about what I have in those
income statements and what I don't. So,
this is actually the official income
statement. So, basically I'm not playing
any games, tax games. This is what I
made in revenues and expenses. But I've
done the traditional accounting thing
which is lease expense are treated like
operating expenses before 2019.
And as a chef, I did not pay myself a
salary. Why wouldn't
I? I own the restaurant, right? What do
I get? I get to keep whatever's left
over. Why would I waste my time
splitting into salary? And it's I get
the money
anyway. You see why this is going to be
a factor? You're going to buy this
restaurant. If you buy this restaurant
based on the operating income, are you
going to overpay for this restaurant or
underpay for this
restaurant? Let's play it out. We pay
overpay and chef is the business. Yeah.
Doesn't work then. In other words, you
pay the 400,000 the day after who's in
the kitchen? You are. And the only thing
you can cook up are structured products.
I don't think anybody's coming to eat
structured products. Right? So, what do
you have to do? You've got to hire a
chef. You say, "I've seen enough shows
on Food Network. I can cook French food.
Try it out." Right? The sule is going to
fall flat. I don't know whether you can
make an egg, beat an egg to make the
white stand up. I've never been able to
pull that off. But I think that's a
requirement to be a French chef is to do
all of those things. So, we got to fix
that somewhere along the way. But these
are the financials. It's not like the
chef is trying to be
deceptive. It's that you didn't you you
have to make sure you ask that question,
huh? You know, do you pay yourself a
salary? So, let's start with the first
step. So I'm going to try to estimate a
discount rate to use to value the cash
flows. So we we the way we built up the
discount rate so far is you get a cost
of equity based on betas, a cost of debt
based on either an actual rating or a
synthetic rating. We took weighted
averages based on market values. That's
how we came up with cost of capital for
public companies. Let's revisit each of
those links. When I use betas, I
implicitly assume that the marginal
investor in this company is diversified
and that the rest of the risk
disappears. As a private buyer, remember
I told you you're taking your entire
wealth and buying this business. You're
the exact opposite of being diversified.
You're completely undiversified. So, I
got to factor that in. The second is I
don't have market values. And why does
that matter? The weights in a cost of
capital are supposed to be market value
weights.
So, let's look at the process you go
through to get over those problems. I'm
going to start the process exactly the
way I would start with a public company.
To get the beta for a public company,
what did I do? I went and looked up
other publicly traded companies in the
space. I estimated a bottom up beta. So,
here I'm going to give you two different
ways and I'll let you pick which one I
think you think is a better way of
estimating that the beta for that you're
going to use value. One is I could take
the beta of other restaurants. I go to
Capital IQ. I download the betas for
publicly traded restaurants. I come up
with a bottomup unlevered bait
of86. But I'll also tell you what's
going to in the list. You're going to
get McDonald's. You're going to get TGI
Fridays. You're going to get
Chipotle. Imagine showing a French chef
the list of companies used as your
comparables. He's not even going to look
at the numbers. He's going to get out of
here. How dare you compare me to Thank
God I'm Friday. It's Friday. It's it's
it's it's not even on the same list,
right? And it doesn't even make
sense. I haven't I don't like French
food. I hope I don't get into trouble on
Twitter because of this. I just don't
like it. But there are people who do.
And how much does it cost to eat at an
expensive French restaurant? A lot.
Right. So, who spends
$200 on dinner? And this is before
drinks, entree, appetizer,
dessert. Two groups of people. One is
really wealthy people or people who feel
really wealthy on that day. The other is
people spending other people's
money. There only two groups of people
in New York who have that much of other
people's. It's lawyers and investment
bankers. So I could go that route and
give you the basis of investment banks
and saying the bait of a restaurant is a
bait for investment banks. Or I could
look at what else these people spend
money at. So the second group that I'm
going to look at are high-end retailers.
Why? Because the same people who eat
French restaurants also shop in that
section of Fifth Avenue between
59th. Where does it stop? Around 42nd,
it's it becomes cheaper territory, you
know. So basically that stretch, right?
Gucci, Farerraamo,
Tiffany's, and the unlevered beta for
those businesses is 1.18. I'll show you
what I picked. But which one did you
pick as your unlevered beta? The
restaurant beta,
the high-end retail beta. I picked the
high-end retail beta. Why? Because betas
measure how you move with the market.
And if you're a high-end restaurant,
you're more likely to move with high-end
retail rather than restaurants. So
that's my unlimited
beta. And if this were a publicly traded
company, I'm almost home, right? But
this is not publicly traded. So here's
where I'm going to bring in what I do
differently with private businesses. So
one way to think about this, you look at
the total risk of a company. Some of
that risk is risk you cannot diversify
away. Market risk, macroeconomic risk.
Some of that risk is company specific.
In a publicly traded company, what do we
do? We focus just on the risk you cannot
diversify away. What happens to rest of
risk? We assume that investors
diversified away. That's what we do with
public companies and that's why we look
at just the beta. But in this case, I
don't have that luxury, right? I'm
exposed not just to this
non-diversifiable risk, but to the rest
of the risk. It's like an algebra
problem. If I could somehow tell you how
much of the risk in a restaurant is
company specific, you could bring it
into your beta and your cost of equity
saying that's the rest of the risk. Now,
if you remember the way we got betas for
publicly traded companies is we ran
regressions. There's a Bloomberg beta
page. There's a raw beta. So you look it
up for each company. But if you look at
that output, there's also an R squar in
that output, right? Remind me again what
R squ measures. What does R squ
measure? Or how much of the variance in
your dependent variable is explained by
your independent variable. Right? That's
a technical definition. What's your
dependent variable here? The company.
What's your independent variable? The
market. Let me rephrase what the R squ
there is telling me. It's telling me the
proportion of variance in my stock that
is explained by the market. Does that
sound familiar? That's basically what
this is, right? How much of the risk in
a company? So the R squar in every
regression is giving you a signal in
this business. This is how much of the
risk comes from the
market. So here's what I'm going to do
with private companies that are not with
public companies. In addition to getting
the average beta for the sector, I'm
going to get the average R squ because
these are all public companies. I can
look up the R
squ and that R 2 is going to become the
basis for what I'm going to do to adjust
your
beta. So here I'm going to throw in a
kind of what seems like a tangential
reality. Betas are measured in terms of
standard deviations.
R squares measure the proportion of
variance that is explained by the
market. So instead of using the R squ
I'm going to take the square root of the
R squ which gives me the correlation. So
I take the average beta for companies
1.18. I take the average correlation and
think of this as an algebra problem. If
I were a diversified investor I would be
okay with a beta 1.18 that half of the
risk that's market risk. But if I'm not
diversified, I'm going to be exposed to
all of the risk, which is twice as high
as the market risk in this case. The
beta that I'm going to see in this
company or Yara is going to see in her
company is going to be 2.36 rather than
1.18. It's the same company because she
sees all of that other risk that
normally would be diversified away. The
lower this correlation becomes, the
higher the total beta effect is because
more of the risk is company specific.
I'm bringing it
in. That's the beta that I'm going to
start with as my unlevered beta. That's
the difference between public and
private. But it's only because the buyer
is completely
undiversified. Now, once I get the
unlevered beta for a public company,
what did I do to get the lever beta? I
brought in the debt to equity ratio of
the company with debt and equity defined
in market value
terms. And here I'm going to run into a
second problem with private companies.
I don't have a market value of equity,
right? It's not publicly traded. There
are three choices I have. One is to call
the owner of a private business and say,
"Can you give me a target debt to equity
ratio?" I've tried this. It never works.
The reaction I get is a target what? I
hang up the
phone. There are two other approaches
and you can try either. One is to use
the average market debt to equity of
publicly traded companies in the space.
What are you implicitly assuming?
There's a reason retail companies have a
certain debt ratio or restaurants have a
certain debt ratio. If I'm a private
company in that same space, my debt
ratio should be roughly similar. You're
a privatelyowned software company. I
would expect your debt ratio to be
really low because publicly traded
companies don't do it. It's going to
save you a whole host of trouble. So,
that's one choice. If that makes you
uncomfortable because it seems like
you're assuming private and public
companies do the same thing, there's a
second choice.
You don't have a market value of equity,
but in your valuation, you're going to
come up with an intrinsic value of
equity,
right? Could you use that to come up
with the debt to equity
ratio? Yes. But it creates a secondary
problem. You see what the secondary
problem
is? It creates a circularity, right?
Because to get the intrinsic value of
equity, I need a debt to equity ratio.
To get the debt to equity ratio, I need
an intrinsic value of equity.
But there's a way around it. If you
check that iteration box in Excel, it'll
take care of itself. It'll actually do
this for you. So the second way to get a
debt to equity ratio for a private
company is to use that that iteration
process and use your estimated value of
equity. But either way you're making a a
call. It allows you to come up with a
lev beta. In my case, I'm going to stay
with the industry average, which is
14.33% for the debt to equity. come up
with a lev beta of 2.56 and a cost of
equity of
14.5%. So, as the investment banker
trying to value the restaurant, you're
going to give it a higher cost of equity
than you would have in a public market
space because your entire wealth is
going to be tied up in the
restaurant. I've got my cost of equity.
To get to a cost of capital, I need a
cost of debt, right?
So, I went to Moody's and I said, "Can
you give me the rating for this
five-star French restaurant?" You know
what I got? Absolutely nothing. Moody's
doesn't go around rating small private
businesses. But there's a way out of
that, right? With public companies where
I could not get a rating. What do we do?
You remember Jake? Don't have a rating.
The interest I compute an interest
coverage ratio and went to that table
and said, "You know what? I'm going to
come up with the synthetic rating that I
can do for private businesses because
all it needs is operating income and
interest expense and I should be able to
get that for a private business. So I
did that for this private business and I
came up with a synthetic rating of
double B+ and a default spread of 3.25%
based on that. I've got my cost of debt.
I'm almost there. I've got this cost of
equity based on what I call this total
beta because it captures total risk and
a cost of debt based on a synthetic
rating. I take a weighted average,
sticking with that industry average debt
ratio. I end up with a cost to capital
of
13.25%. I'm not changing any of the
first principles in how I'm doing, but I
have to be pragmatic. I can't use the
market beta to come up with the cost of
equity because the buyer is not
diversified. That gets factored in.
That's going to be the cost of capital I
used to discount the cash
flows. Any questions about the process?
Right. So all you have as an extra step
is that
correlation of your business to the
market. I don't know where you got the
bottom up betas for your company, but if
you got them off my website, you
probably looked up that table where I
have the industry and the unlimited beta
by industry. If you stay on my data
page, I also have a second table for
total betas, which is basically the beta
that you saw for the restaurant by
industry. So if you're a private
business in the chemical in the let's
say a privately owned chemical company
there's a chemical business and then
there's a total beta for it where I
bring in both the beta and the
correlation to come up with the total
beta by business and those numbers are
going to be significantly higher than
the market beta. Once in a while there
is there are people who go to the wrong
table because they're trying to look up
a beta and they go to my my data set and
they pull the total beta table down not
really recognizing what a total beta is
and then I get this frantic email saying
I'm using your beta p you know your beta
averages by industry and it tells me
that my beta is 3.35 how can it be so
high and I emailed them back saying are
you sure you're looking at the right
beta page and it says beta and I said is
there a word before the beta it says
total beta and I said that's why you're
on the wrong page. That's a page for
people trying to estimate cost of equity
for private transactions. The buyer is
not diversified. It's not meant for
public companies. So you get much higher
basis, much higher cost of equity, much
higher cost of capital.
Yes.
Don't it's not worth it right at this
stage. Don't even mess with that. You
just want to discontin to get started.
Otherwise, this iterative process starts
to multiply in every every side. Right?
So, just stay with market value equity.
Right? Second step, I stopped and
cleaned up the financial statements.
What does that involve? First, do
everything we did with public companies
to clean up the financials. This was 200
whatever, well before the 2019 rules,
leases were treated as operating
expenses. So, what do we do with public
companies? We capitalized leases. We
treated them as debt. If the private
business is R&D, what should we be
doing? Capitalizing R&D. Luckily, this
restaurant didn't have any R&D. Made me
very suspicious. They had a big R&D
expense. What exactly are you doing
research
on? And there's one final adjustment I
made. Remember that chef that you did
not no longer have in your kitchen? I
hired a
chef for you because I don't think you
want to spend your time in the
restaurant cooking food. You can, but
the restaurant will be empty sooner
rather than later. Then it'll go
bankrupt. So, I'd rather spend the
money, hire a chef. name. Remember
though that chef, it's not just how well
they cook, it's whether they have the
profile to draw people in. So my
suggestion is go to the food network,
find a name that people recognize, hire
the guy, and you can probably get away
with them being a very average chef if a
lot of people know who he or she is.
That's the 150,000 that I've added on.
It's something you have to explicitly
ask questions on because no owner is
going to say, "I didn't pay myself a
salary." It's something you have to ask.
It's your your question to ask.
Lisa is valuing her father's consulting
business. And I'm sure how many hours a
day does your dad spend on his
business? Does he ever answer your
calls? He's probably during a certain
time. You have to text him and maybe
he'll get back to you. I guess he spends
a lot of time on his business, right?
No. No. No longer. So there you might
say, look, it won't cost me much. I
could hire somebody from a temp service
to sep for the two hours to do this. But
if you spend 16 hours, clearly you might
need two people to fill that, right? So
you got to be realistic about what
owners do and bring in people to kind of
fill in that
space. Step
three, you got to ask what is the effect
of the person running the business and
especially with small business where
there's a personal component. This is
going to be an issue, right? This is a
French restaurant with a chef. People
come to the restaurant not because they
just want to eat French food, but they
want to eat French food cooked by this
person.
So if he sells you the business and
leaves, there's a very real chance that
some of those people will no longer come
to your restaurant.
Right? In this case, I've estimated that
you're saying, how do you come up with a
20% drop in operating income? Maybe you
got to stand outside the restaurant,
tell and as people leave the restaurant,
say, you know what, the this guy who
cooks here, he's going to leave next
next week. We're going to hire somebody
new. Will you still come back to the
restaurant? I don't know how you do it.
maybe do surveys, you know, some, but
there is going to be a loss. I'll give
you a personal anecdote to show the
effect of this
keepers. I have four kids. They're no
longer kids. They're all grown-ups, but
they were kids once, which kind of goes
without saying, but might as well say
it. And I never had braces, but three of
my four kids had braces. And I realized
how lucrative this is to the people who
I thought you put the braces on and then
10 years later they took it off. It
turns out that it's a repeat business
for dentists, which is they put the
braces on, then you got to come in every
month, they tighten it, they loosen it,
they do all kinds of neat stuff, and
then charge you a couple hundred dollars
for doing that. So, three of my four
kids had braces, and I was responsible
for taking them to the dentist, really
nice guy named
Howie. So, my three kids and I would
visit Howy every every month. and why he
had a factory going of pe kids sitting
in chairs and people adjusting braces
and how he was a master of ceremonies
and he loved talking about the market.
So every time I brought my kids in, he
would be taken and I had this talk. Do
you think I should buy it? And I could
not be rude because three of my kids
there with open mouths, you know, I know
what kind of torture can be inflicted on
them if I give. So I usually and I liked
how he was a nice guy. So I take my
three kids in, you know, one occasion
and he says, you know, I'm thinking of
retiring. And I said, how are you?
You're 42 years
old. He says, you know, I've made a lot
of money. I said, 'I
know. I check my credit card every month
and I see the charge. And he said,
'Well, I'm thinking of selling my
business, you know. Do you think I can
get a lot of money? He said, he
mentioned the amount he made in the
previous year. It's a mind-boggling
number, you know. And he said, "Do you
think?" And I said, "Yes, but you don't
you won't get as much as you think you
you're going to." He said, "Why? Look
how much money I made." I said, "Howie,
you're a dentist for kids.
If somebody buys this practice and puts
them in the chair and I walk in with my
three kids and I say, "Who the heck are
you?" And he says, "I'm your kid's new
dentist." I said, "No, you're not. I've
never seen you
before." People factor that in. They
will discount the
earnings for the fact that you won't be
here anymore. He's a little
disappointed. He said, "Can I do
something to make the discount smaller?"
And he said,
"Yes." I gave him a suggestion. What do
you think he should
do? Not there's actually an
intermediary.
That's one solution, right? Can he have
his cake and eat it too? Can he sell it
and not have the key person discount? He
has to do something for it to happen.
I said, sell it and stay on for a couple
of years. I said, he said, but I don't
want to keep working. I said, "Get a
nice massage
chair. Put on some air, you know, put
get some nice music, sit in the chair,
and when your patients come in, walk
them over to the chair, you know, kind
of make small talk. How was really good
at small talk, introduce them to the new
dentist, kind of transition this
period. It means that you have to wait
two years to leave, but you're going to
get a much higher percentage of
value. And if you're the person buying
this practice, you know what? You have
to absolutely get in that sales
contract, right?
You want to make sure that Howie can't
start a dental practice next door and
suck up all your patients, right? That's
going to be a worst case scenario. You
buy the practice, the next day Howe
opens next door, all your patients go
next door. You're sitting there say,
"Where are my patients? They're all next
door with Howi." something you don't
think about with public companies but
key person issues come up in fact this
is something I know about a year I used
to think that this was something
specific to private business but it
turns out that key people are involved
in almost every business right even at
publicly traded companies and it doesn't
always have to be somebody at the
top it could be a key top manager why
because they set the narrative for the
company will Nvidia be less less
valuable if Jensen Wong is not there. I
think so because in a sense he's viewed
as the driver of the business. That's
mean he sets a narrative for the
company. But the key person could be a
key
salesperson. Let's say you have four
salespeople. One one can be really good
and account for half of your revenues.
You buy the business and that person
leaves. There goes half your business,
right? It could be a key spokesperson,
maybe an outside spokesperson. Say, "Why
would my value rest on outside
spokesperson?" You know, the day Tiger
Woods drove his car into a
tree, Nike lost $4 billion in market
cap.
Why? He was their central player, right?
He was a celebrity. He was a He was the
spokesperson, the the face of the
franchise. the day Michael Jordan left
basketball and remember that one year he
spent playing
baseball in again Nike lost a few
billion dollars in value people saying
you know what you built your entire
business around the Air Jordan I don't
think they're going to do the same thing
for a baseball Jordan because he's not
as
good it's kind of a cause it could be a
key it could be a key design
person you heard of John
Iive. Nobody's heard of John
IV. He worked at Apple or the you know
he left about 5 years ago but he was the
person in charge of design at Apple. So
when you look at your iPhone that is a
jo you look at your MacBook basically it
reflect and Apple is a company that
thinks seriously about design. It's a
company where actually people buy stuff
because it looks cool.
could be a design person. It could be a
key production person, right? If you
have a factory, there might be a a
person, the foreman of the factory who
basically is really good at making
things run on time. The person leaves,
the factory falls
apart. The most unlikely scenario is a
key finance
person. There's not much finance people
can do that's special or unique, right?
What are you going to do? lower the cost
of debt
single-handedly. Change the beta for
your company. Maybe you can pull it off.
Pull a different Bloomberg beta. Look,
I'm beta magically went down by half.
But that's pure
deception. Key people can be at every
part. And to value a key person, the
process is always the same. You value
the company twice. So think of it as a
switch that you turn on and off, right?
The first you value the person with the
key person in the company and the second
you ask yourself what would happen to
the company the key salesperson left the
key celebrity spokesperson is
damaged that difference is the value of
the key person you know the company
should try this on Tesla who's the key
person Musk 10 years ago the switch on
and off had with the effect was
absolutely undeniable right the switch
with with Musk off. Tesla was worth a
lot
less than with the switch on
today. Cut both ways. You turn the
switch. Is it on or off? I have no idea.
The value seems to be more. That's the
effect of the key person effect becoming
more
muddled. So key people can be involved
with private company can make a
difference. So in this case, I'm going
to assume that the key person cost you
20% of your operating income. In this
case, a chef leaves, 20% of your
revenues leave. And just because you're
valuing a private company doesn't mean
you can forget all the stuff we talked
about in the context of valuing public
companies, especially in the context of
growth. Remember the lesson with growth.
To grow, what do you have to do? You
have to reinvest money. How much do you
have to reinvest? It depends on your
returns on capital. That is not just for
public companies for true for every
business. Here I'm going to assume that
the restaurant will continue to grow its
income at the inflation
rate. I'm allowed to grow it up to the
risk-free rate, right? Why am I not
setting it at the risk-free rate? I'm
setting it the inflation
rate. What's the difference between the
risk-free and the inflation rate? That
real growth you're going to get, right?
I don't want real growth here because
what does it mean when you have real
growth in a restaurant? You can't just
put more chairs in a restaurant, fill
the space up. It's already filled up.
You can't have three seings instead of
two. Remember, it's a expensive French
restaurant. You can't rush people and
say, "It's been an hour and a half.
You're taking too long. Leave now." It's
basically what it is. So, if I'm putting
in real growth, I either have to expand
the restaurant or build another
restaurant, and I really don't want to
deal with that. If you told me those
were your plans, I'd bring it in. But
here, I've left the inflation rate. So,
you're saying, "Why would I need to
reinvest if I'm growing just the
inflation rate?" Because those ovens,
those fancy French ovens you have in the
kitchen, will have to get re replaced
every 10 years, right? And if there's
inflation that's driving up your
revenues, that inflation is also going
to affect the cost of the French oven
which has to be built in. So that
reinvestment rate of 10% is what you're
spending to maintain the kitchen and the
restaurant in working order because you
got to continue to generate. I
considered actually making it just a
finite set of cash flows. You see why
with a privately owned restaurant you
might want to do it. What does the
restaurant sit on? land and a building
that you've leased, right? Let's say
it's a in this case a 12- year lease,
and you're not sure whether you can
renew the lease after 12
years, you might say, "Look, I'm going
to do this for 12 years. The end of the
12 year, my my the land owner, the
building owner might increase my lease
by 300%." Knowing that I make money. So
you it's a choice with private companies
you might not you might make of having a
finite life because the business is not
going to last
forever. So I'm ready to do my
valuation. I start with the adjusted
operating income adjust for what the 20%
drop in the key person leaving. I take
out the tax effect. My cost of capital
is 13.25%. I grow at the inflation rate
and given that growth rate, I have a
reinvestment rate of
10%. Remember, if you're already in
stable growth, I don't have to do 10
years of cash flows. It's a waste of
time. I'm going to get the same answer.
Might as well use the stable growth
equation right now, which is expected
earnings next year after taxes minus
reinvestment. So, it's the same
definition of free cash flow. Divide by
my costic capital minus growth rate. I
get a value for the restaurant of 1.4.
million. But there's lease debt, right?
The equity in this restaurant is worth
whatever the value of the restaurant is
minus the present value of leases. I get
521,000 as a value of equity in the
restaurant. If you look at that number,
it's actually like four times net income
in the previous year, which sounds like
a really low number, but that's what you
get when you end up with higher discount
rates, not much growth in a private
business. Any questions about the
process? There's one final step, right?
I have to bring in ill
liquidity. The problem again, I think,
is not that illquidity is shouldn't be
considered as a factor. I think it
should. It's how to bring it in because
you can't just apply the same discount
to every private business. It should
vary across companies. Talked about
healthy versus unhealthy, money-making
versus money losing. It should vary
across time. in a crisis market or in a
in a in a nice buoyant market. And
third, it should vary across buyers,
long-term, short-term. Already, you can
see that if you're a private company
appraiser, there's more you do in this
process than in a public company valuing
the company, right? Because you got to
know who the buyer is. You got to ask
questions. You think that's a lot of
work. Be glad it's a lot of work because
with a public company, Chat GPT can
replace you because it's all mechanized.
With a private company appraisal, you
might have to bring something to the
table that an AI entity might not be
able to
do. So, I'm going to talk a little bit
about illquidity discounts in private
company valuation, how it's done, and
why I think we need to rethink
it. In most private company valuations,
the appraiser values a company using DCF
or whatever they call as a DCF and then
they knock off 20 to 25% maybe 30% of
that value for illquidity. It's like a
standard part of the process and there
are two sets of studies that they use to
back up that big discount because it
serves them well to knock value off.
You're saying why is it good to knock
value off? Because 80% of private
company valuations are for tax
purposes over legal purposes. We want to
show a low number because you want to
pay less in taxes. So they want a lower
number. So the big 30% discount works in
that favor. So the first set of studies
are studies of what are called
restricted stock. Remember to observe an
liquidity discount, you want to be able
to pick something where you can see what
the price would have been with liquidity
and the price without liquidity. That's
tough to do in a private company
transaction because all you observe is
the transaction price. Restricted stock
or stock issued by publicly traded
companies where if you buy the stock,
you're restricted from trading that
stock for it used to be two years. Now
it's one year from the time the stock is
issued. Do you see how this is like a
gold mine for people who look at
liquidity? They're publicly traded. So
you can observe the market price on the
regular shares. Then you can see what
people pay for the restricted shares and
that difference is an illquidated
discount. So for 50 years now private
company appraisers have used restricted
stock studies to back up 30 35%
discounts.
The other set of studies and this is
more recent last 30 years is to look at
what happens just before companies go
public that preIPO in the months before
6 months before cuz if you're let's say
there are five venture capitalists in a
private business and you're going to go
public in 6 months and you want to just
cash out and you're trying to sell to
another venture capitalist even though
you might have an expected offer price
you're not going to get it right because
you're cashing out early because you
want the cash now you don't want to wait
6 months. You can observe the price at
which those transactions happen relative
to the IPO price. It's going to be a
discount. You can observe that discount.
They're both incredibly flawed
statistical and we'll talk about why,
but those were the basis for the big
discounts that private company
appraisers used. So, let's start with
restricted stock studies. For much of
the early part of the restricted stock
study research, first 20 or 25 years,
here's what researchers did. They took
all companies that issued restricted
stock. They looked at the
discount that people demanded when they
bought these shares and they reported a
median value 30% 35%. And then
appraisers took that and ran with it. 30
to 35%. They'd go in front of court and
say restricted stock studies tell us the
discount is 30 to 35%. We've knocked off
30 to
35%. And you moved on.
about 25 years ago. Bill Silbo used to
teach her used to teach the foundations
of finance class in the MBA program
before my class did a study and he
laughs about it because he did it as a
throwaway research study during a summer
where he looked at the restricted stock
studies and he looked at the discount on
each transaction and then he said, "Can
I explain the differences? Why do some
of these stocks sell at lower discounts
than others?" And he found that
companies with high revenues the
discount was smaller than companies with
low revenues. He found that money-making
companies the discount was smaller than
money-making companies. And he set up a
regression. He said let me try to
explain the differences in discounts
looking at the revenues whether you're
making money or losing money whether the
company has cash and finally whether the
buyer of the restricted stock has some
other relationship with the company
because maybe they'll accept a lower
discount. That was
the so collectively restricted stock
companies give you a benchmark 20 25
30%. And what Bill Silver is saying that
discount should be different across
different companies. So I actually took
Bill's study and I ran with it. I said
okay let's say your base discount is
25%. This study allows me to quantify
what happens to that discount as
revenues get higher. It should get
smaller. This study also tells me what
should happen to that discount if you
have a money losing versus a
money-making company. So here's a table
that I drew and here's how it would work
if I were a private company appraiser.
Say I set up office. I'm a private
company appraiser. You come in with your
company. I value a company and then I'm
going to get ready to apply a discount.
I ask you how much do you have as
revenues? Let's say you say $100
million. Then I ask you do you make
money or lose money? And you say I make
money. $100 million you make money. you
should have a discount of about 23%. If
you said you lost money, the discount
would have been almost 30%. Next person
who walks in has a billion dollars in
revenues is making money, the discount
is going to be closer to 16%. So
basically, I'm taking my base discount
and using that regression to adjust what
that discount should be based on money
making, money losing. I'm starting to
move towards a discount that's going to
vary across companies rather than be a
fixed number in every company. But it's
built on the restricted stock studies
which might as I said might themselves
be fatally
flawed. So what I'd like you to think
about is statistically what is the
problem with a restricted stock study?
What where do you think the statistical
problem
comes? So take the median discount. What
happens when you're a company issuing
restricted stock? You got to offer it at
a discount of about 30 35% on the
current market price, right? That's a
lot of money to leave on the table. So
why would a company do that? Why would a
company issue restricted
stock? You're desperate, right? You're
weight watchers. Nothing is working.
What do you do? You offer a huge
discount. You know, in statistics, your
one of the biggest sins is sampling
bias. Do I have a sampling bias with
restricted stock? Absolutely. My sample
is composed of incredibly crazy
companies on the verge of
disaster. So a big chunk of that 35%
discount has nothing to do with
liquidity. It's got to do with my
sampling
bias. Look at the IPO studies because
the numbers there. Sometimes I read a
study and I said there is zero chance
that this study is actually true.
They're published studies. It went
through the review. I don't care if it
went through the review process. it
doesn't pass the smell
test. The IPO studies don't pass the
smell test. So, here's what you do in
IPO study. You take companies that go
public. You look at their offering price
and then you work backwards in the 6
months before the offering. You look at
transactions that happen and you see how
much the prices were lower on those
transactions. How much of a discount?
And these studies claim there's a 40 to
50%
discount on the offering price. And
there is no chance that is true. And
here's why. Let's say you're a venture
capitalist in a company. It's planning
to go public six months from now at $100
per share. Would you sell your stake to
me at $50 per share? You'd be out of
your mind to do it, right? No. So I
remember I, you know, I sat on one of
these research study presentation. I
said that is not true. That cannot be
true. But they said we have the data. I
said okay. So what do you have data on?
They said, "We took every company that
went in public. We went back and this is
true." Where's the bias coming in? Looks
like they've done things right. They've
counted every company that went public.
What did they not
count that? But still uncertainty still
doesn't mean a 50% discount, right? The
expected value
should
not is every company that plans to go
public actually go
public? No. Some companies talk about
IPOs and they pull the IPO, right? You
know what the stud is missing? It
started with companies that went public
and work backwards. What should have if
you truly wanted an IPO study, what do
you need to do? You need to look at all
companies that plan to go public and
record these transactions, including the
companies that never went public. And
they're the people who sold early will
actually end up with this much higher
number than the company was worth. The
bias is coming from the fact that you're
missing those companies, the companies
that never went
public. So both these studies are
insanely biased because of sampling
bias. But for four decades, private
company appraisers got away with this in
courts. And you know who the biggest
loser from this was, right? The
IRS on the other side. You might have no
sympathy for the IRS. But essentially,
that's less tax revenue being collected
because you're letting people mark their
companies down 30, 35, 40%. So the way
the IRS played, they they were cheap on
their expert witness. So here's what
would happen. The private company
appraisers, the expert witness would get
up there and say, "Discount should be
40%." The IRS's expert witness would say
based on the restricted stock studies,
they'd go to the lower end, 30%. And
what do the courts do? They'd split the
difference and give you a 35% discount,
which is a win for the taxpayer,
right? Until one final day, the IRS
decided to actually spend the money and
hire a guy who knew
statistics. And he said the problem here
is not with the high and the low end.
It's just there's a sampling bias. And
he actually went through that 35% median
discount and he broke out how much of
that discount was because of ill
liquidity and how much from the sampling
bias. He concludes 22 22 23 24% of that
discount comes from the sampling bias.
So today private company appraiser much
shakier ground now because there's
somebody in the other side say hey look
the sampling bias took them a while but
they still stick with it because their
response is what else can we
do my response is there's something that
you can do what did we say was the
discount with publicly traded stocks the
bid and the ask price right can I
observe that with every publicly
absolutely if I took that spread and
stated as percentage of the stock price.
I'm getting a measure of the illquidity
discount across every publicly traded
company, right? Think of my sample size.
It's not the 60 restricted stock
companies. It's every so there's no
sampling bias. And if I take that spread
as a percentage and relate it to
differences across public companies that
I can also get for private companies for
the level of revenues, whether you're
making money or losing money, even the
trading volume, I can tell you which
kinds of companies have high bid assets,
smaller companies, money losing
companies, companies with the trading
volume is really low and which companies
have really low spreads. companies like
Apple, big companies, money-making
companies, lots of liquidity. And that
equation that I have for the spread, I
can use to get a spread for a private
business. Say, what what's a spread even
do for a the bid as spread is a measure
of the illquidity in the company. So, if
I can get that estimate for a private
company, I've essentially got an
illquidity discount. So, let's see how
this plays out. If I took my restaurant
and I used the bludgeon approach, which
is what appraisers use, I just knock off
25%. Why? Because I do that for every
company. If I did the refined bludgeon
approach, I don't even know what a
refined bludgeon would be. But I start
with the bludgeon and adjust for
revenues, I do get a number that's
higher because this is a really small
restaurant.
But if I take the bid ass spread and
plug in the numbers for this company,
the re the revenues, the fact that it's
money-making, and the fact that you
never trade. It's basically like a
publicly traded company that never
trades, I get a bid spread that's 12.88%
of value. Saying what does that tell me?
That is my estimate of the liquidity
discount at this business reflecting its
revenues, its fact, its money making,
the fact that it never
trade. I think this has, you know, that
regression you saw though is about 10
years old. You're saying why haven't you
updated? Because it was a pain in the
neck to
do. I went to Capital IQ. I look for if
Capital IQ gave me a bit aspirate, I
would do this every month. It' be
no-brainer, right? Capital IQ does not
have I don't know why they have a float
percentage, all kinds of crap, but no
bit aspirate. There's a different
database which has a bit aspirate. I had
to combine two databases of thousands of
companies. I will never do that again.
Actually, let me take the maybe I'll do
it again one day. But I don't want to do
it every
year. But that's if I were a private
company appraiser, I would do it because
this is my livelihood. I'm not a private
company appraiser. So if they want to do
it, they should do it. I'm not doing it
for them. Why would
I? But I think it offers more chances of
getting a better estimate.
So that's private to private. Everything
that is a mess will kind of play out.
Let's talk about private to publicly
traded companies. Let's see what's going
to be different. You're telling publicly
traded
company. The company doesn't have to be
diversified. Its investors can be
diversified. Right? So the that total
beta discussion goes out. So I can use a
market beta. And ill liquidity is no
longer an issue because once a public
company acquires you, investors can be
liquid because they can trade the
shares. So here's the first thing I did.
I recomputed the cost of capital and if
I do if it's a buyer of public company,
your cost of capital is going to go back
to a market beta. Cost of capital is
going to be much lower 8.76%. You don't
have that diversification issue. And
when I actually value the company,
there's no liquidity discount either
because that 11.8 12.88% disappears. So
take a look at the difference in value.
If I sell to a private buyer, I get
453,000 or
454,000. But if I sell the same
business, the same restaurant to a
publicly traded company, I get
$1.484 million. Ready? You can be the
owner of the restaurant, the chef.
Right? 454,000 is your value selling to
another private individual. 1.484
million is your value if you sell to a
public company. Obviously, you'd like to
get the 1.484 million,
right? Which one are you more likely to
get and what will it depend on first? It
depend on who's sitting across the
table. If it's a private individual,
it's going to be 454,000. If it's a
public company, will you get the 1.484
million? You're going to start your
bidding at 1.484 million. Right. But if
I'm the public company, what am I going
to counter you with? 454,000. No, no,
not start at 1 million. And I'll start
at $455,000. I'll try to be bananimous.
I'm giving you $1,000
more. And guess if if that plays out as
a bargaining, who's going to win that
bargaining game?
Usually the public company. I might pay
you
500,000. I'm doing you a favor. 46,000
more than you could have gotten another
transaction, but I'm walking away with
900. And if I do this on restaurant
after restaurant and I roll them up and
I make this a public company, think of
how much value I'm going to be able to
gain. You know, at one point in time,
garbage businesses across the country
were local and owned by families
controlled by the mafia in some cities,
but that's a different story, right?
And a company called Browning Ferris
came along and what it did was basically
roll up private businesses across the
country and essentially become a
publicly traded company and it created
immense value along the process for
itself because it claimed that
difference. But you can see private to
public essential. So if you're a private
business owner negotiating with a public
company, odds are you're not going to
get unless you can pull off something.
What do you have to pull off as a
private business owner to try to get
closer to 1.484
million? Get another get another public
company involved, right? Because you get
two public companies trying to buy you.
They they know the value is 1.484
million if you're lucky. So the key here
if you're a private business owner is to
find the right buyer. Hopefully the
right buyers, two buyers who are
diversified, let them play off. Would
your answer have been different if it
were a VC or a private equity investor
on the other side instead of a public
company? What would be different?
Most VCs tend to be sector specific,
right? Technology. So they're not fully
divers. They're more diversified than
that individual who tried to buy it, but
they're not. So they're going to fall in
terms of the correlation somewhere
between the individual investor who's
not diversified at all and market. If
your potential buyer is a private equity
investor, does the identity of the
private equity investor make a
difference? It's KKR or
Blackstone? They're publicly traded
companies. They're diversified across
multiple businesses. They should be. You
can see why even within this space if
you look at the bidding it can be
different depending on where you fall in
that
spectrum set up at least private company
for an
IPO. Everybody understand the process in
which most companies go public around
the world. Let's say you're a private
business and you want to go public. Why
would you go public? Why would a private
company go public?
One is it allows owners to cash out,
right? That's one venture capitalist
etc.
But you were raising capital from VCs.
So why is it better for you to raise it
raise your equity from public equity as
opposed to VCs?
What you might get better terms, right?
Remember that that beta effect, right?
The the total beta effect almost. So you
decide to go public. Going public comes
with a whole stack of other stuff you
have to do, right? You have to file a
prospectus. You have to have information
disclosure. So, it's not an easy
decision. Companies delayed sometimes.
And we'll talk about the characteristic
companies. You decide to go public.
What's the next step after you decide to
go
public? You hire a banker. At least
historically. What does a banker do?
They create a
syndicate. Sounds like a mafia again,
but it's like a banking mafia. And what
does the syndicate do? They go, they do
a first before they even do a road show,
they test
out prices. They call investors and say
you have this company and know how much
would you pay. We'll talk about that
process. Then they take you on a road
show, which means they try to go around
and market you to investors and then
they price your company towards the end
and then they guarantee that price. It's
called an underwriting guarantee. Sounds
like a great deal, right? Wait. So why
do they do this? Because they're
magnanimous, sweet people. Or what what
is it that bankers get out of
this? No, but they have to get something
even without the price shooting up
because right they get six they get a
percentage of the capital you raise. If
you're raising 100 million, they get to
keep 6 million,
right? The price rising they don't make
money on because remember they don't buy
the shares. It's somebody else who makes
money on the shares.
So, let's talk about what you would do
if you had to value a company for an
initial public offering. This was my
valuation of Twitter in October 5th of
2013. October 5th of 2013 was the date
that Twitter filed its prospectus for
its IPO. They announced they're going to
go public. They filed a prospectus. I
when I value companies for IPOs, I like
to value them right after a prospectus
is filed and before the bankers even
start to mention prices per share. You
know why? Remember we talked about bias,
right?
Subconsciously it's going to weasel its
way into your head, right? So banker
said $20 per share whether you like it
or not the $20 is going to start to so
when you do a valuation you get seven.
You say I must have done something
wrong. Let me try a higher growth rate.
So this was my initial valuation of
Twitter. And my initial valuation I did
almost everything I would do with a
public company which is know a story
about growth and margins and
reinvestment. The story I told was of an
advertising company, an online
advertising company that would succeed
as a secondary advertising place for
most advertisers. Why? Because a
Facebook or a Google can be your primary
advertising, but Twitter I felt would be
something you'd advertise on in addition
to something that kind of reduces the
market size, but it was still a pretty
successful story at the end. That gave
me margins and cash flow. So if you
think about the FCF simple Ginsu
spreadsheets, revenue, growth, margin,
sales capital, I did that and then I
estimated cost of capital just as I
would do for a public company, right?
Because it is in fact effectively a
public company. saying how do you get a
beta since I never used regression betas
to begin with that wasn't an issue I use
the beta of the online advertising
companies on I finished my valuation I
get a present value of the operating
assets what do we do then we usually add
cash right and here comes the one
additional step I had to do for Twitter
that I do would not do for a public
company what does going public mean you
have an offering you issue shares when
you issue shares what
happens cash is raised Right? And you
got to tell me what you will do with
those offering proceeds. In the case of
Twitter, they were going to keep the
proceeds in the company. What does that
mean? The day after the offering, what's
going to happen to their cash balance?
It's going to increase by the offering
proceeds, a billion dollars. The day
Alibaba went public, they raised 20
billion in their initial offering. Their
value jumped by 20 billion because
effectively your cash balance went up.
So that's the one technical change is
you see that all so to value an IPO
you're not doing anything different than
with the traditional any other company.
The only difference is you got to figure
out what to do with the proceeds. So
first thing is I'm going to talk about
the different things that can be done
with proceeds in an offering and how
they play out differently in evaluation.
The second is by the time a private
company goes public it's accumulated a
whole set of investors venture
capitalists and each venture capitalist
has come with his own or her own
security that they've created preferred
shares. There's a multiple classes of
shares and warrants and options all that
have accumulated for the company that
you got to take care of got to deal
with. The second is the process itself
is going to affect the number you put in
the company. What do I say investment
bankers do? They look at your company
and they try to put a number on your
company that they hope to get on the
offering day. Is this a pricing mission
or a value mission? What's your job as a
banker? That's clear, right? Demand and
supply. It's a pricing mission. So,
you're going to see a pricing start. And
in addition, you've given a guarantee,
right, of that price. So once you get
that price, do you want to discount the
price or you want to reduce your risk or
put a premium on the
price? You want to discount the price
because if you set the price too high,
you got to come up with that money.
Investment bankers are actually open
about this. Say price the company, knock
it down 15%. Because that means we have
less risk to
face. So here's the first thing. When
you look at the proceeds, there are
three things that you can do with the
proceeds. One is you can keep the cash
in the company, which is what Twitter
did. The second was what Spotify did on
their IPO where they let VCs and owners
cash out, which means the cash just goes
through the company. It's a conduit.
That's the easy valuation. You can just
ignore it. The third is if you're a
private company that's accumulated a lot
of debt, you might use the proceeds to
pay down the debt because you really
shouldn't be carrying debt. In which
case, where will it show up in your
valuation? through the debt ratios in
your cost to
capital. Whenever you look at a
prospectors, check the prospectors out
because somewhere in the prospectors,
they will tell you what they plan to do
with the
proceeds. So, there are IPOs that are
happening even now. You can check out
the prospectors. In the case of the
Twitter prospectors, they told me that
they were going to raise about a billion
dollars and they were going to use it in
the company. They're going to keep it in
the company. That's why you saw me add a
billion. In fact, if I told you that
they were going to keep only half of
that and let owners cash out in the
other half, what would he have done
differently? I added a billion, which
was the proceeds. If only a half was
kept, we would add half of that. Right?
This is not
basically they just you know whatever
proceeds remember effectively if you're
an owner the day of the IPO your
ownership is converted to share count
right you could some of your so
basically your share
count that this has to be pre-arranged
before the IPO so basically these are
transactions that are arranged because
if you don't then you get locked in so I
will stop with that next class when we
We'll talk about, you know, what to do
about those other claims and how it
plays through
me again.
perfect ECF and
then send me the
game email to
Thank you. A lot.